là monsieur bonsoir je voudrais regarder
la france au fond des yeux nîmes
j'aimerais beaucoup qu'ils aiment
apprendre à tricoter à votre place je la
ramène un peu moins que les si vous ne
réussissez pas c'est qu'il vous manque
qu'une seule chose un tout petit détail
le trophée des valises à paris qu'est ce
qu'il lui arrive à la bleue
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
l'inattendu l'émission qui décrypte
l'actualité contemporaine grâce aux
archives de la télévision dans quelques
minutes la comédienne et chanteuse lorie
pester reviendra nous parler de
l'endométriose une maladie qui touche
une femme sur dix dans notre pays mais
d'abord notre revue de presse
hebdomadaire avec géraldine cornet
lavaud et ludivine lopez journaliste à
la rédaction dina bonjour à toutes les
deux à l'heure vous ludivine cette
semaine vous avez choisi nous parler
d'une enquête sur les maisons de
retraite qui qui fait débat en ce moment
oui un livre enquête au titre évocateur
les fossoyeurs sorti cette semaine alors
le journaliste victor castanet pointent
les défaillances des maisons de retraite
et les dérives lucrative de certaines
d'entre elles parmi les révélations de
l'auteur il est aussi les maltraitances
envers les résidents témoignages et
documents à l'appui alors ce n'est pas
la première fois qu'une investigation de
ce genre a lieu dans les archives nos
documentaliste ont trouvé celle ci elle
date de 1998 une enquête à l'initiative
de la rédaction du magazine 60 millions
de consommateurs
scandale loi du silence 60 millions de
consommateurs dresse dans son dernier
numéro une liste noire des insuffisances
dont sont victimes les personnes âgées
qui ne vivent plus chez elle outre les
foyers les hôpitaux de long séjour il y
aujourd'hui en france
5673 établissement public ou privé
ces structures accueillent au total six
cent mille personnes du troisième et du
quatrième âge
trop nombreuses sont les maisons de
retraite ou disons pour le prépayé la
qualité de service est extrêmement
médiocre c'est à dire qu'au delà de la
morale ou disons aucun consommateur
n'accepterait d'être prêté de cette
façon et de payer un prix tel pour des
prestations qui sont souvent très
médiocres 60 millions de consommateurs
dénonce également des locaux inadaptés
ou dangereux une mauvaise qualité
l'alimentation et du personnel en nombre
insuffisant ou peu qualifiés enfin la
revue évoque la maltraitance
l'inattention le manque de respect dont
sont victimes de nombreuses personnes
âgées
voilà c'était il ya 24 ans lorsqu'il
faut préciser ainsi que le journaliste à
l'initiative donc de cette enquête
pointe du doigt un groupe de maisons de
retraite en particulier le gouvernement
s'est saisi de la question et demande
donc des comptes des réponses à ce
groupe en question un anniversaire avec
vaud géraldine à il ya 60 ans le
couturier yves saint-laurent présenté sa
première collection à paris une
collection qui n'est pas passée
inaperçue oui et pour l'occasion
plusieurs musées parisiens comme le
louvre à lui rendre un hommage
yves saint-laurent ses 40 ans de
carrière et c'est surtout une pièce le
smoking pour femme présentait pour la
première fois au défilé automne en 1966
jean rêverait d'en avoir un c'était une
petite révolution à l'époque parce que
jamais avant un couturier n'avait fait
porter un smoking à une femme alors les
réactions on l'imaginé était vive dans
les années 60 mais ils pouvaient compter
sur catherine deneuve ou sur françoise
hardy on voit sur ces images pour
défendre ce smoking pour le porter
magnifier et pour yves saint laurent
attention c'est intéressant parce que
pas de militantisme dans ce vêtement
empruntées au vestiaire de l'homme mais
plutôt une vision de la société moderne
vous adorez vous les pantalons mais il
ya beaucoup d'hommes qui n'ont que le
pantalon n'est pas féminin du tout
j'adore le pantalon en effet je n'aime
pas le pantalon lorsqu'il est portée
d'une façon revendicatrice et à dire je
suis l'égal de l'homme je pense qu'au
contraire en portant un pantalon une
fameux peut développer son maximum de
féminité justement pour lutter contre
contre lui voilà cette interview de 10
alors on fait penser à gaspard ulliel
tragiquement disparu il y a quelques
jours et qui était absolument formidable
dans dans l'incarnation du saint laurent
merci beaucoup géraldine alors voilà
pour l'actualité de cette semaine que
s'est il passé à cette même période de
l'année mais par le passé les api de
l'inattendu
bonjour
aujourd'hui barbie est en prison à la
base l'allemagne fédérale le réclame
depuis mai 82 mais jusqu'à présent
barbie était protégé par le régime des
militaires boliviens qui ont toujours
entretenu de bonnes relations avec les
anciens nazis la france a ouvert une
nouvelle information à lyon il ya
quelques mois contre klaus barbie
l'accusant de crimes contre l'humanité
moubarak dégage inspirés par la
révolution tunisienne c'est en français
que c'est cairote défi le président
égyptien et la foule reprend en arabe
dégage dégage des tracts avaient convié
toute la population algéroise à
manifester dans les rues la fièvre
montait au fur et à mesure des jeux que
les heures pas fait on commençait
arraché des panneaux on commençait déjà
à préparer les barricades
le
grandiose immense fabuleux à lui seul ce
jeune homme employé les trois
qualificatifs les plus à la mode au
stade de france ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir mon esprit
c'est le premier en stack sur la route
de l'elysée pour tous les candidats à la
présidentielle ils ont jusqu'au 4 mars
pour déposer leurs parrainages au
conseil constitutionnel 500 signatures
de maires de députés de sénateurs deux
conseillers régionaux ou départementaux
une condition sinequanone pour avaliser
leur candidature et ça ne plaît pas à
tout le monde effectivement à cette
règle est très critiquée cette année par
plusieurs candidats comme eric zemmour
marine le pen ou encore jean luc
mélenchon qui a carrément parlé de coup
près des critiques encore plus forte
cette année car les parrainages ne sont
plus anonymes et jean luc mélenchon a
demandé à une réforme express du système
en vain saviez-vous en revanche que
cette quête des 500 signatures n'a pas
toujours existé
non je ne savais pas
sait-on que la démocratie française
permet à tous les citoyens d'aspirer à
la plus haute magistrature en 1947 pas
besoin de 500 signatures chaque français
peut prétendre à l'elysée voici dans son
bourg monsieur renoir vernisseurs y mène
sa campagne à coups de canon un canon
qui comme dit l'autre n'a jamais tué
personne mais en 1962 avec la réforme de
la constitution
les règles changent
le président est dorénavant élu au
suffrage universel direct et il y à
quelques contraintes le candidat doit
être appuyé par 100 personnes mais pas
n'importe qui pas n'importe qui il faut
que ce soit des élus d'au moins 10
départements différents et voilà comment
le système de parrainage est né sans
signature suffisait à l'époque pas assez
pour certains vous même vous vouliez
aller plus loin exigé 2006 et bien moi
j'avais demandé 2000 signatures pour
donner davantage de rigueur il fallait
une assise électorale extrêmement
élargie et n'ont pas réduit à 100
signatures ce qui fait que ce qui ne
permet pas malheureusement d'écarter les
candidatures fantaisistes
écarter les candidatures fantaisistes
voilà le but des parrainages une
contrainte qui va se renforcer en 1981
où les prétendants doivent récolter 500
signatures de quoi agacer certains comme
l'écologiste brice lalonde il n'hésitait
pas à porter ses feuilles de parrainage
sur les plateaux télé alors je voudrais
publique l'eau puisque vous êtes pour la
démocratie vous demander de prendre
l'engagement
et je vais vous faire transmettre ses
feuilles et de signer pour un candidat
qui ne soit pas celui de votre parti je
ne vous donnerai pas ma signature quelle
que soit la sympathie que je peux avoir
pour certaines de vos préoccupations
bien tenté mais raté les fameuses 500
signatures sont d'aucune quête de tous
les instants surtout pour les petits
candidats qui ne sont pas portés par des
partis pour une quête qui fait l'objet
de nombreux sujets télé tous les
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
continuent leur chasse aux fameuses
signatures la chasse aux signatures il
lui manque encore 19 signature la chasse
aux signatures qui se poursuivent et à
chaque fois les maires qui sont les élus
les plus nombreux sont courtisés mais
pour certains on ne leur fait pas nous à
chaque fois l'issue est la même c'est la
poubelle
ce qui importe pour le candidat c'est
d'avoir des 500 signatures penser ça le
mr bah il est temps qu'ils passent que
pendant sept ans il entend parler de
rien voilà des signatures sans doute
plus politique qu'il n'y paraît en tout
cas il faut convaincre les élus et c'est
pas facile non c'est pas facile et je
voulais dit parce que ça se corse encore
plus cette année avec des parrainages
qui sont maintenant 100% public diffusé
publié deux fois par semaine alors les
élus ne veulent plus trop se mouiller de
peur de ce voile à 2 d'avoir le conseil
municipal après qui demandent des
comptes voilà c'est vraiment pas évident
mais grâce aux documentalistes on a
trouvé une petite archives une petite
astuce pour trouver ses 500 signatures
ces cadeaux alors voilà je voulais
explique sa part que vous avez raison en
2002 une voyante aider le front national
à s'adresser au maire qui était
susceptible de paris les hante une
voyante donc l aiguille et les les gens
du front national face au maire qui
était susceptible de parrainer jean
marie le pen ça vaut le détour
elle n'a pas de carte politique juste un
jeu de tarot patricia est voyante dans
le pas-de-calais depuis quelques
semaines elle cherche des signatures de
maires pour la candidature de jean-marie
le pen
bon je le fais pas par pure amitié quoi
maintenant si je peux les aider mais je
les aide si vous voulez par rapport à je
fais pas je les dirige par rapport à mon
travail de voyance quoi aller signer à
l'époque perdez pas votre temps
sa méthode elles sont des listes d'élus
locaux et à latence ce qu'elle appelle
le bon flash
voilà le bon flash qui faut-il le
rappeler en 2002 avait plutôt marcher
parce que jean marie le pen était voilà
enfin en tout cas pour l'instant ils
sont plus d'une trentaine être candidat
à cette candidature il y en aura sans
doute un petit peu moins le 4 mars
prochain merci beaucoup
[Musique]
l'endométriose est au coeur de
l'actualité ces dernières semaines
l'assemblée nationale a voté à
l'unanimité une résolution porté par la
députée la france insoumise clémentine
autain pour reconnaître cette maladie
comme affection longue durée quelques
jours plus tôt emmanuel macron annoncé
une stratégie nationale de lutte contre
l'endométriose une pathologie qui touche
une femme sur dix dans notre pays alors
pour en parler avec nous la chanteuse et
comédienne de rip hester elle est notre
invité cette semaine bonjour vous êtes
atteinte d'endométriose laurie vos
combat contre cette maladie voulais
partager notamment dans des livres sur
les réseaux sociaux c'est quoi
concrètement l'endométriose
l'endométriose site une maladie
chronique de l'appareil génital féminin
en fait c'est l'endomètre qui se
développe en dehors de l'utérus et
qu'ils peuvent attaquer aussi d'autres
organes ça se manifeste comment
contourner atteindre d'endométriose ya
plusieurs de plusieurs façons et ça
dépend aussi des femmes mais en tout cas
c'est des douleurs atroces
pendant les règles et il pas que ça peut
être un peu avant et après aussi direct
ça peut être des problèmes digestifs des
douleurs pendant les rapports quand on
va aux toilettes
des douleurs dans au niveau du
diaphragme
alors l'endométriose a longtemps été
présenté comme une maladie taboue mal
connue des professionnels de santé donc
mal diagnostiquée ludivine pourtant
cette maladie a été découverte il ya
longtemps oui c'est peu de le dire elle
date de
1860 le chemin a été long et ont
constaté en regardant les archives avant
les années 2000 peu de choses peu de
reportages des missions sur le sujet à
la télévision
mais grâce à nos documentaliste et après
une longue recherche on a trouvé dans
les archives le premier témoignage d'une
femme atteinte d'endométriose c'était il
ya 51 ans en
1971 dans le magazine féminin
aujourd'hui madame l'émission était
consacrée à la stérilité madame
gestuelle marié deux ans de mariage
ce que déjà ça représente pour vous un
drame
oui peu d'autres pas et moins dangereux
je sens au début du mariage est très
très lié et puis dès l'instant où j'ai
su que j'aurai deux os difficulté à un
enfant on s'est sentis séparer enfin et
puis alors surtout par le fait qu'on ne
puisse pas avoir de rapport
régulièrement enfin j'ai une
endométriose malienne bilatérales et
j'ai de grosses difficultés pour avoir
des rapports je souffre terriblement et
je sens que mon mari se détacha fin
volontairement je m'en sens responsable
ce que vous pensez que ça peut aller
jusqu'à la rupture
je crois voilà c'était gelé dix ans il y
à 51 ans donc
cette femme qui pose le mot endométriose
à la télévision ça vous fait quoi
d'entendre ce témoignage lors et ben ça
fait ça fait bizarre parce que parce que
je ne savais pas du tout quand on avait
parlé déjà à l'époque quelques cette
femme même 10 voilà j'ai mal pendant les
rapports j'étais problème avec mon mari
enfin je trouve que pour l'époque
c'était c'était courageux de venir
parler d'endométriose et on entend à
cette femme elle dit se sentir coupables
culpabiliser de sa maladie et même des
répercussions que ça pourrait avoir dans
son couple elle envisage même une
rupture est ce que c'est un sentiment de
culpabilité ce sentiment de culpabilité
vous l'avez ressenti aussi vous l'aurez
c'est c'est quelque chose qu'on ressent
ouais parce que parce que déjà oui par
rapport au couple parce que le parfois
notre notre compagnon est là
c'est pas quoi faire on est mal on est
potes bouillotte on peut rien faire on
peut parfois même j'avais la culpabilité
je pouvais pas porter ma petite parce
que j'avais trop mal au ventre on reste
couchée des journées entières donc
culpabiliser parce que on peut pas aller
travailler on ne peut pas faire tout ce
qu'on voudrait pendant les rapports
voilà l'ol sans son mari qui commence à
se détacher et c'est vrai que ben c
c'est c'est oui c'est cette maladie
créer des problèmes au niveau du couple
au niveau du travail au niveau de la vie
sociale c'est ça une répercussions
énormes en fait alors une des
conséquences de l'endométriose c'est la
fertilité l'infertilité selon
l'association endo france 30 à 40% des
femmes atteintes de cette maladie ont
des difficultés à tomber enceinte c'est
un combat que vous avez vous aussi mener
oui oui oui oui bah oui parce qu'en fait
quand on est atteint d'endométriose
on a souvent un traitement médical qui
nous stoppe les cycles donc on a plus de
règle pour plus que la maladie se
propage parce qu'on ne sait pas soigner
cette maladie mais on peut essayer de la
stopper et après pour essayer d'avoir un
enfant il faut arrêter ce traitement là
pour que les cycles reviennent donc en
fait donc ça peut être long difficile ça
peut être long donc les douleurs
reviennent et puis aussi si on si ça
dure trop longtemps en essayant
naturellement bats la maladie se re
propage donc moi ce qu'il s'était passé
c'est qu'on m'avait dit voilà on va
essayer quelques mois naturellement si
ça ne vient pas naturellement faudra
qu'on essaye une pma parce qu'on peut
pas par foyer des coupes qui attendent
enfin qui essayent pendant un an deux
ans trois ans pourra d'un mois jeu
c'était pas possible parce que sinon la
maladie elle ce serait un trop trop
propager et ce qui est intéressant aussi
de voir dans les archives c'est que ce
combat pour devenir mère cette femme en
1971 en parlait déjà à la télévision en
participant à l'émission al espérait
trouver des réponses
mais ce que je voudrais
savoir un enfant est ce qu'avec une
maladie des ovaires par le fait est ce
qu'on peut quand même guérir et avoir un
enfant parce que si tout espoir est
permis
donc la rupture n'est plus en plus
envisagée par le fait le reste à je
crois que dans votre cas précis avec une
endométriose a conduit la condition de
pouvoir la traiter c'est à dire de
bloquer l'ovulation pendant un nombre de
voix suffisant
grosse chance d'avoir un enfant parce
que le vert atteint d'endométriose est
un navire qui pond un oeuf quand même et
il suffit de calmer l'endométriose s'il
n'y en a que sur les ovaires vous savez
à mon avis grandes chances d'être
enceinte à joues blanches et comme
l'espoir
l'espoir retrouvé pour cette femme en
1971 en ce sourire qui en dit long c'est
aussi le message que vous adressez
laurie à celles et ceux qui se battent
pour donner la vie dans l'un de vos
posts sur les réseaux sociaux en
septembre 2020 un mois après la
naissance de votre fille vous les
invités à ne jamais perdre espoir vous
l'aurez vous y avez toujours cru oui
ouais j'ai toujours cru après moi je
suis je suis assez battante donc dans
tous les projets dans tout ce que
j'entreprends je vais jusqu'au bout et
là c'était avec mon compagnon notre
projet j'aurais jamais je n'aurais
jamais laissé tomber c'est quoi le rôle
du conjoint justement dans dans ce
projet dans le quotidien d'une femme
atteinte de l'endométriose c'est pas
facile
c'est pas facile pour eux parce qu'il
faut vraiment qu'ils trouvent leur place
son rôle c'est d'être une épaule sur qui
se reposaient nous rassurer
être positif et puis enfin voilà est
juste être là et à nous écouter en fait
c'est déjà c'est déjà super vous l'avez
dit à l'ats nathanaël tout à l'heure a
effectivement de maîtrise et présentait
encore aujourd'hui comme une maladie mal
connue pourtant ça fait longtemps avec
les scientifiques planchent sur le sujet
exemple en 1986 à clermont ferrand une
conférence consacrée exclusivement à
l'endométriose elle réunissait donc
cette conférence pendant trois jours des
scientifiques de plus de 33 pays
c'est pas pourquoi les femmes ont nommé
trio on sais pas qu'est ce qui les rend
stérile cantal endométriose ou pas
toujours et nos traitements sont à
définir voilà donc la raison de ce
rassemblement de spécialistes autour de
cette pathologie dont l'apparition n'a
pas d'explication claire et pourtant les
perturbations biologique qu'elle
entraîne sont multiples vous avez dit
que c'était la mode à vis de la femme
moderne à tout à fait tout à fait de la
femme moderne car il semble bien qu'elle
est plus fréquente maintenant qu'elle ne
l'était avant et quel serait le
phénomène qui se passerait peut-être le
rythme de vie avec les stress la fatigue
multiples occupations
qui ont induisent et entraîne des
troubles de l'ovulation
lors de maîtrise la maladie de la femme
moderne bon en 1986 elle a encore du
chemin à faire pour comprendre cette
pathologie 36 ans plus tard la recherche
a évolué mais les carences en matière de
formation des professionnels de santé
sont toujours pointés du doigt par les
associations par les malades est ce que
c'est un constat que vous avez fait
aussi laurie
ah oui oui oui c'est quand on en parle
entre entre femmes atteindre 11 chaque
fois on jamais on est tombé à chaque
fois sur des sur des médecins ou des
gynécologues qui était pas du tout
formés qui savent pas de quoi ils
parlent
ils savent pas ce qu'il faut faire enfin
voilà le truc maintenant c'est vrai si
on a des doutes on va faire une irm et
puis et puis de là on voit ce qui se
passe c'est d'ailleurs la moyenne
aujourd'hui pour obtenir un diagnostic
est toujours de 7 ans selon
l'association en offrant ce comment
est-ce qu'on peut pallier cette errance
déjà ainsi déjà tôt tous les médecins
voient la fin mais les médecins
les gynécologues à l'école oui en parler
beaucoup beaucoup dans les collèges dans
les lycées si vous avez vraiment mal
pendant vos rêves attendez n'attendez
pas aller tout de suite consulté et puis
essayer d'avoir des centres dans chaque
région de france pour que pour que les
gens puissent aller vraiment dans un
endroit pas loin de chez eux alors c'est
intéressant parce que on a quand même
une discussion avec vous loris ans sans
tabou ça n'a pas forcément été le cas
par par le passé à la télévision
ludivine dans les archives à partir de
quand l'endométriose est elle devenue un
sujet de société et bien au début des
années 2000 à cette époque donc il ya
des malades qui se regroupe des
associations qui voient le jour les
campagnes d'information et de
sensibilisation se multiplient et la
parole vous en parliez laurie la parole
se libère à la télévision des femmes
racontent leur quotidien des reportages
leur sont consacrés comme celui ci en
2005 c'était sur france 3 et à pâques et
douleurs pendant les règles et à ostie
des douleurs pendant les rapports il ya
des douleurs quand on va à la celle et
ceux du beurre pour les pourris nez il
ya beaucoup de douleur tous ces
symptômes là on n'en parle pas on s'est
dit c'est normal on est une femme c'est
s'est ancré dans nos têtes et
et malheureusement il faut sortir tout
ça de l'ombre alors pour sortir tout
cela de londres comme dit cette femme
une semaine européenne de prévention et
d'information sur l'endométriose existe
depuis 2004 à l'initiative des
associations
elle aura lieu cette année du 7 au 13
mars est-ce qui a aussi participé à
lever le voile sur l'endométriose il
faut dire laurie c'est le témoignage et
l'engagement de personnalités comme vous
mais aussi comme l'actrice laetitia
milot l'animatrice enora malagré la
chanteuse imany ou encore julie gayet
votre parole vous laurie vous l'avez
porté jusque dans les ministères
oui oui bah oui en fait j'ai eu la
chance de rencontrer
la ministre de la santé à l'époque agnès
buzyn j'avais écrit un petit texte qui
avait été qui avait été diffusé le film
punk post donc pour parler
d'endométriose et aussi de congélation
d'ovocytes ces thèmes et de mes deux
combats et donc j'ai eu la chance oui 2
après après ce texte 2
d'autres invités et
et de la rencontrer et on a passé un
moment vraiment enfin je peux pas dire
super mais elle était très à l'écouté
elle avait très envie de faire bouger
les choses de faire changer les choses
d'organiser des tables rondes avec des
professionnels des patientes donc voilà
déjà à l'époque c'était c'était un
engagement qui était il voulait elle
voulait vraiment elle faisait justement
des annonces à la télévision en 2019
concernant l'endométriose nous allons
créer des filières de prise en charge
dans toutes les régions de façon à ce
que les femmes sachent vers qui se
tourner afin qu'elles soient mieux
accompagnés pour la prise en charge de
la douleur alors des filières de prise
en charge dans toutes les régions c'est
ce que promettait donc agnès buzyn en
2019 trois ans plus tard c'est toujours
ce que prévoit entre autres emmanuel
macron dans son plan de lutte contre l
endométriose est ce qu'il n'ya pas la
lorie quand même un petit goût de
réchauffé dans ses annonces de
réchauffer
bas-fonds peut-être qu'il y en a ils
vont le prendre pour du réchauffé en
tout cas c'est ce et c'est long à mettre
en place c'est pas évident donc je pense
pas que ce soit dur et chauffé je pense
que ça ça fait un petit moment que tout
le monde travaille dessus et que bah
c'est seulement aujourd'hui quand on a
un résultat quoi
merci en tout cas laurie d'avoir accepté
notre invitation et merci pour votre
témoignage sincère et
efforts tiens je vais je vais quand même
rappeler le livre le titre de votre
livre c'est pas si compliqué c'est des
astuces pour positiver au quotidien et
c'est vrai que quand on souffre de
pathologies comme l'endométriose on est
en quête de signes positifs donc voilà
donc c'est c'est votre livre le riz
merci mille fois merci à vous ludivine
pour pour ce dossier on va se quitter
avec notre traditionnel pépite
d'actualité d'ailleurs un chandeleur
oblige voici une recette de crêpes signé
du cuisinier raymond olive air en
1954 notez bien les proportions surtout
la recette d'entre eux mais le plus
simple est certainement les crêpes
quelle fatigue transport de laval
le parfum est composé de deux choses
autre chose danny ainge par là et malgré
que ce serait dur à cette lan décès du
rhône qui rentre comme partant
principalement je vous en mets environ
trois fois 6 ou deux fois plus que je né
me danese alors je vais la détendre
c'est à dire l'allongé avec la bière au
long blanc la forme plutôt rivière de la
bière voilà là nous sommes prêts de
crainte qu'elles ne sont pas grasse et
le sont sèches bon je pense que cette
recette va plaire à nos spectateurs qui
n'ont pas de flou
voilà des crêtes bien sûr à consommer
avec modération pour on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine sur le canal 27 et
bien sûr sur les réseaux sociaux que ce
soit seul in house de france info
émission préparée avec les
documentalistes laurence mattioli et
pascal au bar et merci à elle et merci à
vous d'être là chaque semaine
[Musique]